cj chrome to start the second
cj a couple of home runs early has
struggled lately his last 10 advance or
so get going goes the other way and it's
deep that ball is
gone
cj crone starts our weekend out strong
most hitters are better when they don't
try and pull the ball cj right there
waiting going the other way using that
power
see this ball out over the plate
elevated a little bit and cj weights and
barrels
eric gonzalez he brought in the pirates
runs with a single
back in the second inning 2-2 count
and there's a drive hold that one e gone
clear the deck cannonball coming eric
gonzalez beyond the left field looney
bleachers the second deck that is an
absolute
monster shot his first
and it's 4-1 estimated distance on that
home run
463 feet
now stephen follows chad cool four
strong seven strikeouts for cool brawl
didn't record and out
32 pitches
three hits
three walks
three runs
tigers
have deadlocked it at four and are
looking for more
him tigers have the lead
another rbi for cj crone and now we'll
see phillip evans there's one two to
evans
evans lifts one toward
center field sending jones back and
out of here phillip evans just hit a
three-run homer into the bullpen
his first big league home run for philip
evans well he is seizing this
opportunity and you
talk about clutch victor reyes at second
base with two away and the tigers down a
couple of runs here in the sixth a
chance for jacoby jones
that's a fair ball go reyes will score
jones has himself
a two out rbi double and the tigers have
pulled who they won
i like it
there's a
there's a uh what do you call it cross
up another cross up yeah
i thought it still should have been a
strike yeah it was right down the middle
even if it's a cross up who cares
hey just threw him out
he said knock it off and ramon dejesus
just threw out shelton and then derek
sheldon is continuing to argue with
jesus right now and that's why i'm going
to start talking very loud and very fast
so you can't hear what he's saying
because he continues to talk with the
umpire and if he says something that we
don't want to be on the radio i'm just
going to keep talking right now because
derek shelton is still arguing with
ramon de jesus right now down behind
home plate he's the home plate umpire
who has ejected derek shelton kristen
stewart here in the seventh with the
bases loaded
drives one to right center and that's
gonna drop in front of tucker
one run will score that scope cabrera is
forced to stop at third and the bases
remain loaded
stewart comes through
big time to tie it at seven
the 2-0 from del pozo swung on ripped to
left that's a base knock cabrera scores
krone will score
and that's a two-run single for jammer
candelario the tigers in front 9-7
reyes singled and scored in the sixth
here's the o2
that's stroke to left and that's gonna
drop in front of reynolds
going all the way home and an rbi single
from victor reyes and a season high in
runs for the tigers so far one and one
now to goodman has just one hit from the
right side this year
ball to center going back is tucker and
that's going to be off the wall he'll
take a two-run double instead
and nico goodram pads the tigers lead to
five and he snaps an over 16 skid so
eric gonzalez with the bases loaded
line to right fair ball eric gonzalez
ropes it into the right field corner
two in
what a night for him
six
runs batted in pirates down three
the pirates will bring the tying run up
here in the ninth here comes adam
frazier
frazier with a fly ball hit well toward
right center field approaching the wall
out goes fascia
to tie the game
on a 1-2 pitch
adam frazier ties it at
wow
12.
a comeback a 12-12 game amazing oh well
lugo went over to sunday against
cincinnati
1-1 shoots it the other way and comes
through
jones will try and score and he will be
in there because it's close to play by
john ryan murphy at home plate and the
tigers lead at 13 12. so now it's cole
tucker with a chance to at least tie it
the infield in a pop-up
to center looks deep enough for murphy
yeah he's gonna have to throw the second
on this one and it will be a tie game as
cole tucker a sacrifice fly makes it
13-13 candelario's got a couple of hits
tonight couple of runs scored as well
that's a fair ball into the right-field
corner harold castro will score how
about a three-hit night for jamer
candelario yeah the one one to goodwin
oh that's a rocket to right and that's
gonna be over the head of tucker good
room in the second and the tigers tack
on two more thanks to the second two run
double of the night from nico goodroom
down to their final batter frazier homer
tied the game in the bottom of the ninth
this is gonna do it
jacoby jones
tigers win the first of this
three-game series
17-13 we're on garden highers club
goes to six and five